some questions that come up all the time
in statistics are
what are z and t tests what's the
difference between the two
and then how do you know which one to
use well i'm here to break all that down
for you
i'm richard and this is richard undata
so for those of you totally unfamiliar
with z and t
tests let me give you the bare building
blocks
when you have some phenomenon that
follows a normal distribution
and then you calculate a z-score that is
the number of standard deviations that
an observation
is away from the mean that z-score
is actually a random variable in and of
itself
with two parameters specifically this z
statistic is normally distributed with a
mean equal to zero
and a standard deviation equal to one
and in fact
that's used to build confidence
intervals and hypothesis tests in a
whole range of different scenarios
but then you've got what's called the t
distribution
so it looks a lot like the normal
distribution it has that same bell curve
to it
except it does have wider tails so
let's say you calculate a t statistic we
say that t
statistic follows a t distribution which
has one parameter
and that's its degrees of freedom so you
say okay that's wonderful but
how exactly do you know which of these
tests to use
i'm going to talk about the scenarios in
which you're going to use these things
and then how exactly to use them but
before we get into all this
please take one moment of your time to
smash the like button to this video
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
also subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and hit the notification
bell so youtube notifies you whenever i
upload a video
and then lastly i do have a link in the
description of this video to my patreon
account
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over that way that would be
massively appreciated
so the most important thing to do before
you start thinking
anything about things like test
statistics and distributions
is to ask yourself what problem you're
trying to solve
and many statistical problems are going
to come down to either finding an
interval estimate
or testing a hypothesis about a
population proportion
typically represented by the letter p or
a population mean
generally represented by the greek
letter mu
obviously there are extensions like for
when you have a difference in population
proportions
p1 minus p2 or a difference in
population means
mu 1 minus mu 2 but the same principle
is gonna hold
now let's start actually with the case
of proportions because
these are actually a little bit more
straightforward
and again we want to estimate or conduct
a test
about a population proportion p well in
this scenario
we'll have conducted a sample of size n
and we're going to come up with some
kind of estimate that's our sample
proportion p-hat
now i'm going to give you a possible
real world example
let's suppose i was really interested in
the true proportion of my subscriber
base
that's on the social media website
reddit
now suppose i did some super scientific
survey
the sample size that i got was n equals
100
and i came up with an estimate of p hat
equals 0.6
that's of course the first step but
let's suppose
i want a 99 confidence interval for that
true proportion p
well for proportions we use z statistics
all around
so the formula for this confidence
interval is going to be p
hat plus or minus z star
times the standard error of p hat where
the standard error of p
hat equals the square root of p hat
times
1 minus p hat all over n you can use a
lookup table or you can use
r or some statistical software to find z
star but we do need to find z star at
the 99
confidence level so i'm going to use
this freely available table
it's going to be linked to in the
description but when i look it up
i get z star equals 2.33
now we just plug numbers in and we get a
99
confidence interval of 0.486
to 0.714 now that z star that i used
there
is an example of a z statistic but now
let's suppose i was conducting a
hypothesis test instead
the same kind of thing is going to apply
let's say i want to conduct a hypothesis
test that a majority
that is p greater than 0.5 of my
subscriber base use
reddit and let's say i conducted the
exact same sample here
so again p hat equals 0.6 and equals 100
and we use a 5 significance level so the
test statistic here
is z equals p hat minus p naught
over the square root of p naught times
one minus p
naught all over n where p naught is the
null proportion which is point five here
do the math here and i get z equals
2.236
like i said right at the beginning of
this video that z
statistic is a normally distributed
random variable
with mean equal to 0 and standard
deviation equal to 1.
so i'm looking for here as my p value
the probability that we observe
in a standard normal distribution a
value of z
equals 2.236 or greater
again use a table like this or use r
i get a p-value of .0127
and because this is less than our
significance level that we set up at the
beginning of 0.05
we would reject the null hypothesis and
we would conclude that
yes a majority of my subscribers use
reddit
now that we've looked at the case of
population proportions you may be asking
okay what about population means well
before we get into any of that
it is super important to understand the
concept of the central limit theorem
and i did a full tutorial on this but
here's the quick summary of it
suppose we're taking a sample of size n
from some distribution
n is of reasonable size let's just say
25 or greater
and then even if that distribution we're
sampling from
isn't normal x bar that is the sample
mean
will be approximately normally
distributed
with mean equal to the population mean
mu
and standard deviation equal to the
population standard deviation
sigma divided by the square root of n
just as an example
let's suppose you knew that the
distribution of iqs was
skewed to the right with a mean equal to
110 and a standard deviation of 15.
now you go and you take a sample of size
100
and you want to know the probability
that the mean of that sample
is greater than or equal to 115. well we
know the population mean and the
population standard deviation here
so we can calculate the distribution of
x bar
it's going to be approximately normally
distributed with a mean
equal to 110 and a standard deviation
equal to 15
divided by the square root of 100 that
is
1.5 this turns into a probability
calculation with the normal distribution
where you just calculate a z-score like
you always do
solve for z and you get z equals 3.333
then you just do a standard probability
calculation you find the area to the
right of z
equals 3.333 is 0.0004
that's your answer all this is is just a
probability calculation from the central
limit theorem
the thing that you have to realize is in
the real world
when we want to make some confidence
interval or a hypothesis test about an
unknown population mean
you can bet that we don't know the
population standard deviation either
it's precisely for this reason that for
these types of calculations
we use what's called the t
t-distribution instead
and the t-distribution has wider tails
than the standard normal does
because the fact that we don't know
population standard deviation
creates additional uncertainty hopefully
that that makes sense now we're gonna go
through the same types of examples of
confidence intervals and hypothesis
tests
for population means coming back to our
iq
example scrap all the numbers that i
gave you before
let's suppose we took a sample of size
50 we come up with a sample mean of 105
and a standard deviation of 14.
now we want to create a 95 confidence
interval for the population mean iq
the formula for that is x bar plus or
minus
t star times the standard error of x bar
just like before t star can be looked up
using
r or from using a table that's freely
available on the web
and the standard error of x bar equals s
divided by the square root of n
where s is the sample standard deviation
do the math here and we're going to get
almost
exactly to a confidence interval of 101
to 109
now let's use the exact same numbers in
a hypothesis testing scenario
so again sample size is 50 sample mean
is 105
and sample standard deviation is 14 and
we want to test at a 5
significance level if the population
mean iq
is greater than or equal to 100 our test
statistic t
is equal to x bar minus mu naught
over the standard error of x bar where
again standard error of x bar
is s divided by the square root of n
plug in and do the math
and we get t equals 2.525
use a table or use r and we end up with
a p
value of .0074
that is the area to the right of t
equals 2.525
so we soundly reject the null hypothesis
and we conclude that yes
the population mean iq is greater than
100.
that about covers it you've seen both
confidence interval and hypothesis
testing scenarios for z-tests
and for t-tests as well as an example
from the central limit theorem
now i haven't shown you slightly more
complex scenarios
like when you're dealing with
differences in population proportions
or differences in population means but
the exact same principles are going to
apply
hopefully now you understand which type
of test to use
and why so thanks everybody for watching
this video
if you enjoyed it once again smash the
like button
and then leave me a comment down below
and let me know which one you tend to
use more
the z-test or the t-test then i'll see
you all in the not-so-distant future
until then richard on data